es ist acht uhr abends willkommen zu der
wanne show
[Musik]
hey leute hier zu teure mal waren und
willkommen zu einer neuen folge ich habe
viel zu viel geld ausgegeben für dinge
die ich höchstwahrscheinlich doch
vielleicht nicht brauche
da der erste teil von gntm produkten
fast richtig gut da ich angekommen ist
dachte ich mache ich auf jeden fall den
zweiten teil denn es gab sehr viele
produkte die bei gntm noch getestet bzw
gezeigt wurden durch castings durch
kooperationen durch irgendwelche random
ein spieler ihr kennt den spaß
ich habe dieses mal wieder ganz tief in
die tasche gegriffen bei manchen dingen
freue ich mich sehr drauf andere sind
halt nicht so ein spaß wie zum beispiel
diese kaltbach streifen die dascha
gewonnen hat ich habe sie beim müller
gefunden man auf diesem streifen sieht
man ganz toll offizieller partner von
germany's next topmodel augenbrauen habe
ich noch nie gewächs ist meine lippen
auch nicht eigentlich sieht man es nie
so toll aber ich habe schon damals gar
nicht so schlimm weil ist halt so es
sind halt haarige gene was soll ich
sagen
die anwendung ist auch ganz easy einige
deiner haut mit gesichtswasser habe ich
schätze deine haut mit herkömmlichen
puder nicht waxing trenne die streifen
langsam und gleichmäßig für die
schönheit
[Musik]
die besitzen wir da drauf strafen ein
teil 3 ich freu mich traurig hahahahaha
sieht man nicht aber es brennt ein
bisschen bei dem casting sache ist alles
viel schöner aus modellen
zum glück hab ich im hintergrund ein
räucherstäbchen an
also ich sehe noch ein paar h rückstände
aber ich glaube das ist normal next one
we have die augenbrauen wie kann die
einheit nicht so vorstellen wie
augenbrauen
das ist die augen bord von aber jeder
hat auch eine andere augenbrauen vor
die reden halt von sonar augenbrauen
form aber die habe ich hier im auge ist
es alles für die schönheit kommt ich
mache jetzt einfach so das wird jetzt
meine form fällt kein keine diskussion
das mache mir jetzt einfach die seite
meine augenbrauen weg aber ich werde
meinen augen nicht abreißen
rip augenbrauen sage ich dazu nur ich
habe keine haare unterhalb der
augenbrauen aber jetzt wo ich die mir
diesen kriegstreiber oder angucke mach
ich hier raus steht mit der augenbrauen
und körpers scheiße zu spät ein 2 3 1 2
1 ok kurzes fazit ich mag die sehr gerne
also es tut zwar höllisch weh aber es
tut halt einfach weg sie reißen aber
alle haare mit und die hautreaktion
danach ist nicht so krass um noch mal
den preis zu sagen zehn euro pro packung
das ist schon das schon luxus artikel
die welt gerade auch dass ich schon ein
paar minuten in diesem video bin und
halt noch nicht so wirklich über james
ex topmodel geredet habe ja alex hat das
ding gemacht war ich schockiert dass zu
liegen als dritter rausgeflogen ist ja
war ich absolut dachte eigentlich sie es
gewinnt aber alex ist natürlich auch gut
also schreibt gerne in die kommentare
was ihr zu dieser staffel zu sagen habt
ich freue mich darauf so nicht machen
wir weiter mit den produkten konsum
konsum konsum und materieller wohlstand
ist das einzige was meinem leben noch
einen sinn gibt da gefühlt jeder der bei
dieser staffel aufgetreten ist irgendwas
mit arbeit zu tun hatte hat wolfgang
joop eine kollektion herausgebracht die
man bei audio kaufen kann für den
kleineren schmaleren geldbeutel seine
schmale geldbeutel marke heißt lux ich
finde die klamotten ganz cool in der
folge wurde dieses casting hatten sahen
die looks eigentlich alle ganz fresh aus
wenn man jetzt aber auf die seite geht
jetzt zum beispiel bei zalando oder bei
youtube das handy klamotten so ein
bisschen altbacken aus ich habe genau
die rosa oh was heißt bluse oder silbern
tolles pink die hatte romina an mein
gelbes hemd kostet 70 euro
jetzt werdet ihr wissen was ich meine es
ist eigentlich ganz cool aber also
dieses aufgestickte hab ich irgendwie
mitbekommen oder sie doch nicht gut aus
oder wir haben 75 prozent viskose und 25
prozent jsl
das gibt mir so ein ganz komisches aber
es ist ja an sich nettes hemd ich
probier sind sahen zwischen dada fashion
ich weiß nicht ob ich es liebe oder hass
irgendwas dazwischen normal fashion
fashion ich meine einzige festival ja
ich mag es die verarbeitung sieht halt
nicht nach übelste quality aus muss man
wirklich sagen ich habe gerne eure
meinung dazu
also dieses komische linke schulter
sieht das ist nämlich zu irgendwo noch
weitere gänge
privat sieht holt euch das nicht bei
joop schaut einfach dass ihr im
secondhand laden ein schönes oversize
helfen würde ich glaube das ist genauso
gut aber mit joop hat hier noch nicht
auf passend zu seiner kollektion hat
auch ein parfüm rausgebracht maik looks
bei wolfgang joop jeremy fragrance hat
das vielleicht noch nicht bewertet aber
das hat dazu werbung gemacht auf ihrem
instagram kanal und meinen dann falls
ihr jetzt angst habe das ist rothe half
aber ich habe meiner schwester die haare
rot gefärbt sieht ganz cool aus ich bin
aber irgendwie für diesen weil ich für
diesen weiblich so kann das deckelchen
ist das ist glaube ich das irgendwann an
recycelten irgendwas am ball sein parfüm
geht es natürlich darum wie es riecht
ich liebe es das ist der perfekte
verfügen dürfte es ist nicht zu süß
nicht so blumig nicht zu
moschus holzig fans richtig gut was das
gekostet ohne es kostet 16 euro und 49
absolut bezahlbar das design ist jetzt
nicht atemberaubend schön und ich stelle
mir das irgendwie toll hin aber der
geruch 10 von 10
und weil ich durfte nicht gut
beschreiben kann sagen wir es mit den
worten der website im auftakt
fasziniertes oder parfüm mit dem
von inga pinken pfeffer und birne ein
hauch von patchouli jetzt weiß ich warum
ich so liebe vereint sich im herzen mit
einem pluralen trio aus branche blüten
rose und dem nachhaltig gewonnen upside
jasmin die wahl basis aus dem zarten
nuancen von praline praline und vanille
kombiniert mit moschus und am barren die
kompositionen gekonnt ab klare
empfehlung zehn von zehn hier an dieser
stelle nun können wir zum absoluten
highlight eigentlich auch der grund
warum ich unbedingt einen zweiten teil
drehen wollte der dyson diese koffer
kostet 500 euro
lasst euch das mal auf der zunge
zergehen 500 euro das hier immer noch
ein gntm video ist habe ich natürlich
die gntm special edition geholt mit dem
gntm special beutel wohnungs- oder ihren
themen draufsteht ich denke mal das
einfach nur ins special
warum kostet dieses ding 500 euro nun ja
weil es nicht nur ein föhn ist sondern
auch bürsten hat und ganz besonders
bleibt diese röllchen sonst habe ich
unter meinem schranken fön glätteisen so
eine rundbürste das habe ich dann alles
liegen hier ist alles miteinander verein
ich habe leider nicht ein rabatt code
sowie isabeau für euch und schon da
hätte ihr auffallen können dass mit
diesem logo irgendwas nicht stimmt fried
die days fridays freibier
ich hab das ding mit nach hause genommen
und habe es präsentiert wie auf einer
tupperparty es ist aber auch einfach ich
finde es genial lohnen sich aber diese
500 euro absolut wenn man das geld hat
wenn man das geld nicht reicht ein fön
glätteisen noch man schon zu hause hat
absolut aus also das ist hier der föhn
aufsatz dann hat man noch so eine
rundbürste zum beispiel und bürsten für
eine bürste dann kann man so
den ansatz ein bisschen kopie noch eine
bürste da gibt es bestimmt ein
unterschied und der geheimnis der
aufsatz ist der hier der saugt nämlich
die haare einfach dran und mach dir
locken warum der dyson weil es natürlich
einen geilsten job gab bei gntm den
romina für sich gewinnen konnte lasst
uns bitte nicht über meine haarfarbe
reden ich bin gerade dabei sie nicht
nach zu färben und eine neue haarfarbe
auszusuchen
eigentlich sollten meine hände sind
feucht sein deswegen nehme ich das
hessischen spray von dieser ganz
unbekannten markt und macht sie ein
bisschen feucht erneute magic happens
problem mit meinem glätteisen waren
nicht immer wenn ich da eine locke
reingemacht hat dann waren die danach so
trocken und spröde und ich das gefühl
durch dieses vorgehen sie gar nicht so
kaputt und jetzt alle dieses videos
nicht spontan jetzt stellt euch mal vor
jetzt leicht feuchte habe dann sind die
locken will i am still
am nächsten dran
idiotensicher ich sag mal so hier konnte
auf 500 euro für ein gerät ausgeben wenn
ihr es nicht drauf habt ihr sich drauf
ich gehe auf denselben dieses party was
soll ich sagen und genauso habe ich mir
meine frisur vorgestellt fertig ein spaß
für die ganze familie
zehn von zehn wovon unsere regieren tm
-kandidaten auch gar nicht die finger
lassen konnten der große bauer grüne
kraft ein veganer joghurt aus hafer
dieser joghurt ist ganz toll denn
experimentiert fermentiert bedeutet der
saß lange rum und das ist gut für den
darm mehr information bekommt ihr von
mir nicht der sieht ein bisschen anders
aus als normaler joghurt hab gerade auf
der packung gewählt der seit 20 tagen
abgelaufen
[Musik]
okay ein gntm produkt habe ich auch noch
immer im letzten video ausprobiert und
zwar das kleid von goal.com london
das ist relativ okay ausgefallen also
für 1000 euro kleid nicht ganz so ihr
könnt euch das video gerne mal anschauen
nicht verlinkt ist somit und jetzt
kommen wir zum großen finale denn eine
modemarke fehlt noch auf die ich mich
sehr freue tatsächlich weil mir die
klamotten sehr gut gefallen und zwar von
lena gercke was natürlich wieder bei
erbaut you verkauft wurde
das probieren wir aber wieder am spiegel
an auf zum spiel gehört main kanal bald
in wanne umbenennen
wenn es so weitergeht naja auf
everybody's darling lena gercke hat eine
eigene modemarke rausgebracht lese ja
habe ich 400 euro dafür ausgegeben ja
habe ich bereue ich ist vielleicht wir
werden sehen ich glaube das konzept von
lea ist dass die sachen leer sind
ich hoffe nur dass ich dieses mal die
richtigen größen erwischt hat das erste
ps eine weiße hose
wow man warum sieht alles was lena
gercke an hat
einfach besser aus lena gercke könnte
sich wirklich ein leser an kartoffelsack
rüberziehen und würde auch darin gut
aussehen also die hose sitzt ganz gut
problem ist nur dieser bereich problems
ich habe die hose ist noch ein bisschen
zu klein obwohl sie schon so groß aus
nähte sie eigentlich lockerer noch
lockerer sitzen von der qualität her ist
okay also es ist eine stabile hose ich
hab da ist nix zu meckern instagram wird
es realität ha ha ha ha ha das nächste
ist ein top jetzt kommen wieder queen
auf transitions einmal nach ich mag das
top man braucht nur im bh dafür
ich zieh mal so einen anderen bh
darunter an jetzt kann ich mich stolz
für euch präsentieren
ich denke mal ran so draußen spazieren
geht dann würde mir das outfit gefallen
aber sobald man sich irgendwie hinsetzen
muss ja ich hab das gefühl kommt kann
man nur tragen als belohnung dafür dass
man die bauchhaut von camila auch
durchgezogen hat für alle anderen gibt
es ja canoe ich habe vergessen dass die
so mies war verarbeitung wird sieht
ordentlich aus 100% baumwolle aus
biologischem anbau
made in china ich habe wenig medien
scheiner vor allem haben die die sind
die klamotten nicht günstig oha das ist
das problem auf unserer erde genau das
was wir gerade gesehen habe ein weißes
falsches und dann gefällt sein trotzdem
und dann sieht man aus wie ein ranger
wie dies eigentlich in school
ich fühle mich schon wie diese models
bei ihr das ist die hose aber die fand
ich auch cool und irgendwie da finde ich
das motto ganz perfekt legere das ist
eine jogginghose ist eine kurze
jogginghose die super kudos wenn man
draußen ist sich gleich mal an die sieht
aus wie ein handtuch ich liebes bisschen
viele hintern daraus guckt trotzdem gute
sommerpause für sie trägt ein bisschen
bauch auf es gibt halt so hosen da man
sich als man das gefühl daheim will
hintern
daraus kann man natürlich so tragen wenn
man möchte dass klose nach meinem
geschmack
lang genug das wird meine sommerhose
dieses perfekte hose coole pose sind wir
beim holly angekommen drehen ist eher
kuschelig mag ich sehr gerne was habe
ich denn für eine größe genommen ist
viel zu klein
ja aber dann kann man ihn so tragen auch
ganz cool muss man ja nicht nur so als
kleid tragen
[Musik]
ich bin verliebt dann wieder müssen so
groß war
online shopping ist so schwer ja das
klassische problem 44 oben 36 das ist
ein hübsches ding ich verstehe den
gedanken dahinter aber es ist nicht
gewagt das zu sein sorgen look mein
fazit leute welches produkt hat mir am
besten gefallen natürlich der dyson und
das per 5 ich bin begeistert von allen
also außer dieser grün kraft joghurt ich
mag diesmal alles und keine sorge falls
ihr euch jetzt denkt man es ja warum
konsumiert du denn in letzter zeit so
viel ich kaufe wirklich privat nächste
deswegen freue ich mich wenn ich dann
mal ein video drehen wo ich mir über
klamotten kaufen kann und ein paar neue
klamotten und den dyson und alles andere
also ja ich hoffe ich konnte eure
kleinen konsum gelüste damit auch ein
bisschen befriedigen
ich kann auf jeden fall alles empfehlen
ich hoffe euch jetzt gut straßen kanäle
dir noch abonnieren können hier gibson
video das noch ein kanal und dann sehen
wir uns das nächste mal wieder leute
also sag mir doch bitte das sieht doch
diese doch hammer mässig aus oder und
die letzte transition tschüss
man sieht mich noch im spiegel oder bei